2 тур зелений перемагає порошенка немає
все пропало, а треба їхати з країни всю
ця країна приречена не це більше
ніколи ми назад ось все нічого не
повернеться немає хлопці не все зникло і
тоді я кажу, що не все зникло і
сьогодні вже тим більше
результати виборів показали нам що до
країні проблеми але якщо боротися якщо
продовжувати боротися як це робить
сьогодні порошенко та команда порошенка то
можна досягати результатів навіть з ось
тієї ситуації коли все зникло
результати другого туру виборів 73 та 22
сотих відсотка були узи ленського
2445 у порошенка це другу тут що
сьогодні нам кажуть рейтингу cmis
опублікував нові рейтинги в яких
якщо у першому турі зелений набирають
19,8 відсотка порошенка 15 7 це цілком
сумірні цифри і вони легко виходять у
другий тур
а що ж на нас сьогодні чекає у другому турі
згодна з дослідженням все дуже
просто зелений набирає 50 5 2
відсотка порошенка 44 8 справа не в цифрах
справа в динаміці тобто що сталося за
цей час ось бачите пару років
динаміка ось така зелінський
Туди готовий знову днище
ось сюди у його рейтинг прагнути туди
вздовж
а у порошенка рейтинг зростає і якщо
а вибори ж у нас не сьогодні вибори ж у
нас буде потім через якийсь час то
величезною і великою часткою ймовірності
порошенко стає наступним
президентом України і не треба кричати
все пропало потрібно просто брати і
боротися потрібно брати і робити брати на
себе відповідальність популізм
в Україні не користується популярністю
популізм
туди в дно і в днище, а реальні справи і
реальні програми та реальна стратегії
розвитку країни вона пульсу популярність
тому всі ті, хто кричав, все пропало
ні хлопці вірте та боріться та
і по борт